and we've got breaking news from the
Vatican where officials announce that
Pope Francis is back in the hospital
this morning Chris libsay is with us
from Rome with more on the story Chris
what can you tell us about what's
happening with the Pope
good morning Gail well Pope Francis is
back in the hospital you can see his
room right behind me over my head in
that row of rooms that have the windows
completely covered in the in blinds now
the Vatican says he's here for an
incisional surgery for a blocked
abdominal wall uh and and this will
require general anesthesia something
that Pope Francis himself has said he
has not responded well to in the past
and this is not his first Health scare
as we all know in March he was rushed to
the same hospital after suffering from
breathing problems that turned out to be
bronchitis and in 2021 he spent 10 days
in the hospital after having part of his
lower intestine removed that was caused
by diverticulitis a painful bowel
condition in fact the pope recently
revealed that his diverticulitis had
come back and now all of these health
problems are in addition to his Mobility
problems so that's pain in his knee and
pain in his hip that's often confining
him to use using a cane to walk and
often times a wheelchair Tony
all right Chris livesay for us in Rome
Chris thank you very much